based on what we saw in the previous
part of the session let's try
multiplying 105 with 97 both numbers are
close to 100 so let's consider the base
as 100 once we decide the base we find
the deviations 105 minus 100 is 5 and 97
minus 100 is minus 3 some on the left
and product on the right 105 plus -3 is
equal to 102 and 5 times minus 3 is
minus 15 as we cannot have a negative
number on the right we subtract 1 from
the left hand figure and add the base to
the right hand figure on the left hand
side we will have 102 minus 1 and on the
right we add 100 102 minus 1 is 101 and
minus 15 plus 100 is 85 that's our
answer
105 times 97 is equal to 10,000 185 you
should try solving the next one it's
easy and I'm sure you will get it right
one thousand and seven times 998 I give
you 10 seconds and your time starts now
we use the same technique base
deviations sum and product we can choose
the base as one thousand both numbers
are very close to it finding the
deviations should have been pretty easy
one thousand and seven minus one
thousand is seven and nine hundred and
ninety eight minus one thousand is minus
two once the deviations are done we
write the sum on the left and the
product on the right one thousand and
seven plus minus two is one thousand and
five and seven times minus 2 is minus 14
what do we do when we have a negative
number on the right hand side we
subtract one from the left hand figure
and add the base to the right hand
figure
subtract a 1 and add the base 1005 minus
1 is 1004 and 1000 minus 14 is 986 as
there are 3 zeros in the base we can
have 3 digits on the right so we can
write a 986 here that's the correct
answer
one thousand and seven times 998 is
equal to 1 million four thousand nine
hundred and eighty six is in this
super-quick with just four simple steps
we can multiply huge numbers in a few
seconds so when the figure on the right
is negative remember to use this
technique subtract one from the left and
add the base to the right but have you
noticed something in all our examples
till date we have chosen the base as a
multiple of 10 10 100 1000 and so on but
what if the numbers are something like
this three hundred and ninety seven
times three hundred and 99 here both the
numbers are close to four hundred can we
choose four hundred as the base don't
worry there is a technique to solve such
examples too we see that in the coming
sessions
you